In this episode we talk about sex in the 17th century. If you're listening with someone who may not be ready for that, you might want to preview it first. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Take a walk through Central London and one building is particularly hard to miss. Just off the banks of the River Tams, the shard is Western Europe's tallest skyscraper. At just over 1000 feet high, the building's slender, tapering design doesn't so much stretch
在本期节目中，我们来聊聊 17 世纪的性。如果你听节目时旁边有人可能还不太适合听这个，建议你先预览一下。这里是 99% 隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。漫步伦敦市中心，有一栋建筑格外引人注目。在泰晤士河畔不远处，碎片大厦是西欧最高的摩天大楼。这座建筑高一千多英尺，其纤细、逐渐变细的设计与其说是拔地而起
into the sky as it pierces through it. 11,000 panes of glass make up the facades which all slope gently inward, rising towards the top so that the building comes nearly to a point. Thousands and thousands of people walk past the shard every day, but there's only a select few who look up at it and breathe a sigh of relief. I just kind of wipe the sweat from my forehead going, you know, yes, thank goodness, that's so bad, it's so standing. This is Roma Agrawal, one of the structural engineers behind the shard. Her job is to make sure buildings, bridges and all sorts of other things withstand the test of time. As a structural engineer, Roma looks at the built world
不如说是直刺苍穹。11,000 块玻璃幕墙微微向内倾斜，向顶部汇聚，使建筑几乎呈尖顶状。成千上万的人每天从碎片大厦旁走过，但只有极少数人会抬头仰望它，并松一口气。我就是那种擦着额头上的汗，然后说，太好了，谢天谢地，太棒了，它依然屹立不倒。说话的是罗马·阿加瓦尔，碎片大厦背后的结构工程师之一。她的工作是确保建筑物、桥梁以及各种其他事物经受住时间的考验。作为一名结构工程师，罗马看待人造世界
with a special kind of X-ray vision. So I might consider what the skeleton of the main structure might be, you know what material is it made from, where do the main bones of it sit and so on. And I also might think, what's underground? You know what's actually holding this thing up? How deep does this thing go? So I'm trying to look beyond the visible. When Roma walks past the skyscraper or over a footbridge,
有一种特殊的 X 光透视眼。所以我可能会去想，主要结构的骨架是什么样的，你知道它是什么材料做的，它的主要骨骼坐落在哪里，等等。我还可能会想，地下是什么？你知道是什么在支撑着这个东西吗？这东西有多深？所以我试图透过表面看到本质。当罗马走过摩天大楼或人行天桥时，
she doesn't only see the main structure. She sees all the invisible engineering that makes that design possible. The small, sometimes hidden inventions that hold up our world. And I have a nut on bolt on my desk right now and I often just hold it in my palm and think if it wasn't for this incredible piece of engineering that sits inside my palm, skyscrapers wouldn't exist. And I think that's kind of humbling and it just reminds you that great engineering, great design, can be really simple and small. Roma recently wrote a book that's actually called Nuts and Bolts, seven small inventions that change the world in a big way.
她看到的绝不仅仅是主体结构。她能看到所有让这种设计成为可能、隐形的工程技术。那些支撑起我们世界的、微小的、有时隐藏起来的发明。我的书桌上现在就有一个螺母和一个螺栓，我经常把它握在手心里想，如果没有我手心里的这个不可思议的工程奇迹，摩天大楼就不会存在。我觉得这挺让人感到谦卑的，它提醒你，伟大的工程、伟大的设计，其实可以非常简单和小巧。罗马最近写了一本书，书名就叫《螺母与螺栓：改变世界微小发明的七大奇迹》。
In it, she takes ordinary objects like the nail, spring, and pump, and shows us how these inventions were actually extraordinary feats of engineering in their own right. The concept of Roma's book is a twist on an old idea. So the Renaissance scientists and engineers, maybe even artists you could call them, came up with a list of six simple machines which were the lever, the wheel and axle, the pulley, the inclined plane, the wedge and the screw. They saw these as being types of machinery that made it easier to move stuff or expend energy or use energy in an efficient way. So that was quite a specific view of what machines do.
在书中，她选取了诸如钉子、弹簧和泵等普通物品，并向我们展示了这些发明本身实际上就是非凡的工程壮举。罗马这本书的概念是对一个古老理念的变通。文艺复兴时期的科学家和工程师，甚至可以说是艺术家，提出了六种简单机械的清单，分别是杠杆、轮轴、滑轮、斜面、楔子和螺旋。他们认为这些是使移动物品、消耗能量或以高效方式使用能量变得更容易的机械类型。因此，对于机械的作用，那是一种相当具体的看法。
But obviously, the Renaissance was a while ago now, and the the world has moved on and things are a little bit different. And I started to think about, you know, even within the very complex technology that we now have, very different from the Renaissance era, what are the little fundamental pieces that I think make up the modern world. And I came up with seven objects, and I always have spirited debates with people, whether they think those are the right seven, or should they be more or fewer, or, you know, but this is my list of seven.
但很显然，文艺复兴是很久以前的事了，世界已经向前发展，情况也有所不同。我开始思考，即使在我们现在拥有的非常复杂的科技中——它与文艺复兴时期截然不同——究竟有哪些微小的基本构件构成了现代世界。我列出了七个物品，我和人们总是会进行激烈的辩论，争论这七个到底对不对，或者应该更多还是更少，但这就是我的七个物品清单。
Ha, ha. Today, Roma Agrawal tells us about her seven basic building blocks of engineering, and how we might understand ourselves better by taking a closer look at the stuff all around us. Okay, so your book starts and you start with the nail. Why the nail? So if you're anything like me and you open your desk drawer, there will be just be, you know, a few nails kind of rolling around in the bottom of your drawer. They're cheap, you get them everywhere, we've probably all had to go
哈哈。今天，罗马·阿加瓦尔将为我们讲述她总结的工程学的七大基本构件，以及我们如何通过仔细观察周围的事物，更好地理解我们自己。好的，那么你的书一开始就从钉子切入。为什么是钉子？如果你和我差不多，打开书桌抽屉，就会发现里面滚落着几枚钉子。它们很便宜，到处都能买到，我们大概都曾为了挂一幅画而把它们钉进墙里。我们觉得我们懂它们的原理，觉得其中涉及摩擦力，或者说，它们把两块木头或其他什么东西固定在了一起。但事实是，钉子的故事实际上是一个关于材料的故事、人类的故事、地缘政治的故事。你可以用非常多种不同的方式来讲述钉子的故事。
hammering them in to a wall to put a picture. And we kind of understand how they work, we kind of get that there's friction involved or that, you know, something is holding our two blocks of wood or whatever it is together. But the truth is that, you know, the story of the nail is actually a story of materials, it's a story of humans, it's a story of geopolitics, you know, there's so many different ways you can tell the story of the nail. Yeah, and one of the ways you chose to tell the story of the nail is by making one yourself, the old-fashioned way. Yeah, so another little thing that I have on my desk is this homemade nail of mine. And it was so interesting to me because I think as an engineer, as somebody who studied
没错，你选择讲述钉子故事的方法之一，就是用老式的方法亲手制作一枚。对，我桌上的另一个小玩意儿就是我亲手做的这枚钉子。这对我来说太有趣了，因为作为一名工程师，作为一个学过科学物理的人，我以为自己懂钢材以及它是如何运作的，这基于它的科学原理以及原子和晶体是如何运作的等等。但实际上，当你去锻造一枚钉子——埃及人就是这么做的，古罗马人几千年来也是这么做的——这是一次完全不同的体验，这是一种非常感官的体验。
science physics, I thought I understood steel and how it works based on the science of it and how the atoms work and the crystals work and so on. But actually, when you go into forge and nail, which is how the Egyptians did it, how the ancient Romans did it, thousands of years, it's a completely different experience, it's a very sensory experience. Tell me more about that. So I was in a forge. It has a particular smell. You can kind of smell the burning coke. You put the rod into the flame. It comes out sort of red. And then I was told that red heart is not hot enough. And it needed to go kind of orangey, yellow, almost glowing, and then you have to quickly take it out, whack it at the right angles in the right sequence. As it cools down, it starts to sound different
跟我多说说那个。我在一个打铁铺里。那里有一种独特的味道。你能闻到燃烧的焦炭味。你把金属棒放进火焰里。它出来时呈现红色。然后有人告诉我，红热还不够热。它需要变成橙黄色、几乎发光的状态，然后你必须迅速把它拿出来，以正确的角度和顺序敲击它。随着它冷却，它发出的声音开始变得不同，
to the pitch of the clanging changes. And this is all very, very quick. And it took me like four or five cycles to make a nail of like heating and heating and then heating and then hitting, but obviously the Romans would have done it in one go. It's kind of remarkable to think about that almost everything the Romans built, there was a blacksmith somewhere that needed to make the nails. And not just one nail, like thousands and thousands of them all meticulously made by hand. Yes, so the Romans did this funny thing in what is now Scotland, where they were creating a settlement and they suddenly were called away back to Europe and they had to abandon
敲击的音高变了。这一切都非常非常快。我花了大约四五轮加热、加热、再加热然后敲击的循环才做成了一枚钉子，但很显然罗马人只需要一次就能搞定。想到罗马人建造的几乎所有东西，背后都需要某处的铁匠来打造钉子，这真的很了不起。而且不仅是一枚钉子，而是成千上万枚，全都是一丝不苟地手工制作出来的。是的，罗马人在现在的苏格兰做过一件趣事，当时他们正在建立一个定居点，突然他们被召回欧洲，不得不放弃
the settlement. And they left a hoard of nails 875,428 to be precise in a ditch which they covered up because God forbid that the local savages get hold of this incredible material, the iron, but also this incredible piece of technology, this engineering, so they preferred that it be buried for thousands of years rather than allowing somebody else to use them. I mean, I never really considered the idea that the nail could be so valuable because you just see them lying around,
这个定居点。他们在一条沟里留下了一大批钉子——准确地说是 875,428 枚——然后把沟填了起来，因为唯恐当地的野蛮人得到这种不可思议的材料——铁，以及这项不可思议的技术和工程成果，所以他们宁愿让这些钉子被埋藏数千年，也不愿让别人使用。我的意思是，我以前从没想过钉子会这么有价值，因为你经常看到它们随处可见，
construction sites and your junk drawer. But they were once a huge part of a global trade. Yeah, so the materials and the skill to make the nails were both scarce things. And there's a story about how when the British were colonizing the world, they banned the export of nails to their colonies, including the USA. So if somebody was leaving one house and going to go away and move to a new place or build another house, they actually
散落在建筑工地和你的杂物抽屉里。但它们曾是全球贸易的巨大组成部分。对，制造钉子的材料和技术在当时都是稀缺资源。有个故事说，当年英国在世界各地殖民时，他们禁止向包括美国在内的殖民地出口钉子。所以如果有人要离开一个房子，搬到一个新地方或者盖另一栋房子，他们实际上会
burned their houses down. And then from the kind of smoking ashes of their homes, they extracted all the nails, bagged them up, swung it over their shoulder, and then went on to build their next house. So in 1619, a law was actually passed in the state of Virginia to ban people from burning their own houses down and assuring them that, you know, if you were, in fact, going to leave a house and leave the nails intact, that you would be given some kind of compensation for that. That is so interesting. And, of course, screws, nuts, rivets, they're around during this time
把自己的房子烧掉。然后从他们房屋冒烟的灰烬中，提取出所有的钉子，装进袋子里，扛在肩上，然后去建造他们的下一栋房子。所以在 1619 年，弗吉尼亚州甚至通过了一项法律，禁止人们烧毁自己的房子，并向他们保证，如果你确实要离开房子并保持钉子完好无损，你会为此得到某种形式的补偿。这太有趣了。当然，螺丝、螺母、铆钉在那个时代也存在，
for you too, but just not in the quantities like the nail because before the industrial revolution, making those fasteners was really hard. Like, you had to cut each individual thread on a screw manually too. Yeah, so nuts and bolts were way more challenging to create because you'd hand cut the outside thread on the bolt. And then you had'd hand cut the outside thread on the bolt, and then you had to hand cut the corresponding thread on the inside of the nut, and then hope that they fit together. And what I find really fascinating about this is that we often think that screws, nuts, and bolts, rivets are much stronger, better versions of the nail. But the nail is not redundant. The nail is still around,
对你来说也是如此，但它们的数量远不如钉子多，因为在工业革命之前，制造这些紧固件非常困难。比如，你必须手动切割螺丝上的每一个螺纹。是的，所以螺母和螺栓的制造难度要大得多，因为你必须手工切割螺栓的外螺纹。然后你必须手工切割螺栓的外螺纹，接着你还得手工切割螺母内部相应的螺纹，然后祈祷它们能吻合在一起。我觉得这非常迷人的一点是，我们经常认为螺丝、螺母、螺栓和铆钉是比钉子更强固、更好的版本。但钉子并没有被淘汰。钉子依然存在，
and I think that's for me what makes it such a great piece of design is that it's endured. Okay, so let's move on to the wheel. Now the wheel is sort of the quintessential example of the perfect invention, but you have a bone to pick with the way that we think about the wheel. I do. I mean, there's a phrase that really grinds my gears. I'm sorry, Roman, but I have to go with these nerdy engineering partners. Yeah, I got it. The book is full of them. Every time I was like, I, yes, it's so good. And basically it's the phrase, don't reinvent the wheel. So, so this is a phrase that we use in, in business, in work, in school, like all over the place, I say, no, no,
我认为这正是它对我而言成为如此伟大的设计的原因——它历久弥新。好吧，让我们转向轮子。现在，轮子可以说是完美发明的典型代表，但你对我们看待轮子的方式颇有微词。确实如此。我的意思是，有一个短语真的很让我抓狂。对不起，罗曼，但我不得不扯上这些书呆子气的工程学梗。好吧，我懂。书里到处都是这种梗。每次我都觉得，我，对，这太棒了。基本上就是这个短语：“不要重复发明轮子”。所以，我们在商业、工作、学校等各个地方都会使用这个短语，我说，不，不，
we've done this thing before. We shouldn't reinvent the wheel. And the reason that this really frustrates me and annoys me is because basically since humans invented the wheel, we have been reinventing it. I mean, put it this way, if we had not reinvented the wheel, we would not have a single mode of transport that had a wheel on it because wheels were in fact not invented for transport. Yes, so this has been a thing that I've been quizzing people on since I've read your book and no one gets it, no one gets it. So for what purpose was the first wheel invented? So we're going back in time about 6,000 years now. We're going to Mesopotamia and people wanted to create vessels to store their food quickly, robustly, out of clay. And so your first wheel was in fact the potter's wheel.
我们以前做过这事。我们不应该重复发明轮子。让我感到如此沮丧和恼火的原因是，基本上自从人类发明了轮子以来，我们一直在不断地重新发明它。我的意思是，换个方式说，如果我们没有重新发明轮子，我们就不会拥有哪怕一种带轮子的交通工具，因为轮子最初其实并不是为了交通运输而发明的。是的，所以自从我读了你的书，这就是我一直在考别人的问题，没人能答对，没人能猜到。那么，最初发明轮子的目的是什么呢？我们要把时间倒回大约 6,000 年前。我们要去美索不达米亚，当时人们想要制作容器来快速、坚固地用黏土储存食物。所以，你见到的第一个轮子其实是陶轮。
And this was a heavy large disk which was made either from clay, from wood, even potentially from stone. And it basically had like a little bulge on its underside, which sat in a little pedestal. And then you could spin the wheel within its pedestal. And it would keep spinning, thanks to momentum. And they could create pots really quickly. And so who was the first person to take this potter's wheel and turn it on its side and write on top of it? It's funny, right? It took potentially somewhere between a thousand to two thousand years for someone to do that, just to turn it on its side.
这是一个沉重的大盘子，由黏土、木头甚至可能是石头制成。它的底部基本上有一个小凸起，放在一个小底座里。然后你可以在底座里旋转这个轮子。多亏了动量，它会一直旋转下去。他们就可以非常快地制作陶罐。那么，是谁第一个把这个陶轮放倒，并在它上面写字……不对，是谁把它放倒并骑在上面的？很有趣，对吧？可能花了一千年到两千年的时间，才有人这么做，仅仅是把它放倒。
And of course, that's because the axle is actually quite a complicated piece of engineering in its own right. And the potter's wheel kind of worked because of gravity, but it wouldn't work on its side. And the first archaeological kind of solid evidence we have of a wheel is on in a site in the North Caucasus region, which is now in Russia, where archaeologists found tens of thousands of ceremonial burial mounds, some of them were created by the Yam Naya community around the fourth millennium BCE, and one of these graves actually contained a man in a seated position on top of a four-wheeled wagon. Buried with what he loved, I suppose, his own like Ford F-150. Yeah. But it's not only this, like when you talk about the reinventions of the wheel, you know, it wasn't just taking a potter's wheel and turning it on its side.
当然，这是因为轴本身就是一个相当复杂的工程学奇迹。陶轮能转动是因为重力，但如果把它放倒就无法运作了。我们拥有的关于轮子的第一项确凿的考古证据，是在北高加索地区的一个遗址中发现的（现在属于俄罗斯），考古学家在那里发现了成千上万个礼仪性墓冢，其中一些是由大约公元前四千年的亚姆纳亚（Yamnaya）社群建造的，其中一个墓穴里实际上包含了一名以坐姿坐在四轮马车上的男子。我想，他是带着他最爱的东西下葬的，比如他自己的福特 F-150。对。但这不仅于此，当谈到对轮子的重新发明时，你知道，这不仅仅是把陶轮放倒。
There's this sort of the innovation of the axle, which is a big deal. But also, wheels themselves have been innovated over time in numerous ways that you describe. What are some of those ways in which the wheel has evolved itself? Yeah, so the Yamnaya Carts, for example, that was found in this grave, was a solid set of wheels. They were made from three planks of wood that were sort of dulled or pegged together. So, you know, here comes the nail or one of its cousins to help us with that. And these would get dragged along by animals.
这里有轴的创新，这是一件大事。而且随着时间的推移，轮子本身也通过你所描述的多种方式进行了创新。轮子不断演进的方式有哪些呢？是的，比如在这个墓穴中发现的亚姆纳亚马车，使用的是一整套实心的轮子。它们由三块木板拼合或用木钉固定而成——所以，钉子或它的亲戚们登场来帮我们的忙了。这些车轮是由动物拖着走的。
They're pretty clunky, pretty heavy things. So when our carpentry skills improved and we were able to use harder metals to create our tools, we then created spoke tweeles. And spoke tweeles, of course, are a big iconography in Southeast Asia. The Indian flag has a spoke to wheel on it. So there's this little flag reference for you, Roman.
它们相当笨重，非常沉重。因此，当我们的木工技能提高，并能够使用更硬的金属来制造工具时，我们便发明了辐条轮。当然，辐条轮是东南亚的一个重要标志。印度国旗上就有一个辐条轮。所以这有一个国旗彩蛋送给你，罗曼。
And this was much lighter. So when you think of the Greeks or the Romans running around the Colosseum in their little carts and things, they had spoke to wheels. They're much quicker and nimble and their feet. But then when we started looking at flying machines in the 17 and 1800s, designers were thinking, well, even spoked wheels are relatively heavy. And if we want to get something up in the air flying, it needs to be as light as possible. So then the wire wheel was invented. And I should say that the spoked wheels are talking about were made out of wood, the kind
这要轻得多。所以当你想到希腊人或罗马人驾着他们的小车在竞技场里奔跑时，他们用的就是辐条轮。它们速度快得多，敏捷得多。但随后，当我们开始在 17 和 18 世纪研究飞行器时，设计者们开始思考，即使是辐条轮也相对较重。如果我们想让什么东西飞上天，它必须尽可能轻。于是，钢丝轮被发明了。我应该说明一下，我们刚才谈到的辐条轮是用木头做的，也就是你在战车上看到的那种，但钢丝轮是金属的，要轻得多。这就是我们习惯在自行车上看到的那种轮子。
you'd see on a chariot, but the wire wheel, that's metal, and it's much lighter. It's the kind of wheel that we're used to seeing on our bikes. Yeah, it is. But again, in one of those kind of funny things, the bicycle wasn't actually invented until reasonably recently, like Sony a few hundred years old. Right. Yeah, you know, I was really intrigued by your explanation of a tire and just what a tire is. Can you say a little bit more about that? Yeah, so I mean, I think the word originates from, from Thai, like tying together a wheel.
是的，确实如此。但同样地，这是一件有趣的事情，自行车其实直到相当晚近才被发明出来，比如只有几百年的历史。对的。是的，我对你关于轮胎的解释以及轮胎究竟是什么感到非常着迷。你能再多说一点吗？对，我的意思是我认为这个词源于“tie”（系、捆），也就是把一个轮子捆绑在一起。
And it was when we came up with the spoke to wheels made from wood. So you've got the hub, you've got all these different spokes that are being put into it and then a rim, but they can get shaken apart on the cobbly roads and so on. So when the iron age shifted into Europe, what people did was to heat up rings of iron and then put a ring around the rim of the wheel. But what was very clever is that they did this while the metal was still hot. And so as it cooled, it shrank a little bit and then compressed the wheel, making it super nice and robust.
那是当我们发明用木头制作的辐条轮时出现的。你有了轮毂，有了插入其中的所有不同辐条，然后是轮辋，但它们在鹅卵石路面上行驶时会被颠散架。因此，当铁器时代进入欧洲时，人们的做法是加热铁环，然后把铁环套在轮辋上。但非常巧妙的是，他们在金属仍然很热的时候就这样做了。因此，随着它冷却，它收缩了一点，然后将车轮紧紧箍住，使其变得超级坚固和结实。
And that thing is a tire. That thing is a tire. The next stop in our tour of Seven Small Inventions that make up the modern world is the spring. To tell us about the spring. So springs, I think, are one of the most versatile of the seven inventions that I've picked. So they come in a huge range of shapes, a huge range of sizes. We often think of the coiled metal ones.
而那个东西就是轮胎。那个东西就是轮胎。我们对“构成现代世界的七大微小发明”之旅的下一站是弹簧。请给我们讲讲弹簧。我认为，弹簧是我挑选的七大发明中最具多功能性的发明之一。它们的形状千差万别，尺寸也各不相同。我们通常会想到盘绕的金属弹簧。
And in fact, when we're typing on our our laptops that's what's stopping our keys from permanently sinking down into the depths of our computers. I mean there is a you know a platonic ideal spring in my head which is like the coiled metal thing and you press down on it and it bounces back up but I mean fundamentally and I never heard this described before until I read your book, is that a spring is this device for storing energy and being released when we need it to, which really broke open my mind of what all the things that could be spring. You know, yeah, so trying to describe what a spring is was probably one of the hardest parts of this book for me actually.
事实上，当我们敲击笔记本电脑键盘时，正是弹簧阻止了我们的按键永远陷进电脑的深处。我的脑海里有一个“柏拉图式的理想弹簧”，也就是那种卷曲的金属东西，你往下按它就会弹回来。但从根本上讲——在读你的书之前我从未听人这样描述过——弹簧是一种储存能量并在我们需要时释放能量的装置。这真的彻底打开了我的眼界，让我意识到原来有那么多东西都可以是弹簧。对，尝试描述什么是弹簧，其实是我写这本书时最难的部分之一。
So, yeah, it kind of broke my brain as well. And I think the first example of a spring, so with my definition or my attempt at a definition, which is, you know, a material where you can deform it, and it stores energy, and then you can release that energy and use it in a way that's useful to you. The bowl of the bow and arrow is a spring. So what you're doing is you're taking a piece of wood or in the case of the Mongolian bows,
所以，它也差不多把我的大脑给难倒了。我认为弹簧的第一个例子，按照我的定义或我对定义的尝试——也就是，一种你可以使其变形并能储存能量的材料，然后你可以释放该能量并以对你有用的方式使用它——弓箭的弓身就是一个弹簧。所以你做的是，拿一块木头，或者像我写的蒙古弓那样，
which is what I write about, quite a complex construction of animal bone and tendons and wood and so on. And you deform it by pulling a string and you've stored some energy in the bowl and then when you release the string that energy is transferred into the arrow and so the arrow can travel much further, much faster then would be possible if we just try to throw it with our arms. Yeah, yeah. So I think that is the most fundamental or the oldest form of the spring. And you mentioned the coiled metal springs that you squish. You also get coiled metal springs that you pull apart.
这是一种由动物骨骼、肌腱和木头等相当复杂的结构组成的复合弓。你通过拉动弓弦使其变形，从而在弓身中储存了一些能量，然后当你释放弓弦时，能量就会转移到箭上，于是箭就能飞得比我们仅靠双臂投掷时更远、更快。是的，是的。所以我认为这是最根本、也是最古老的弹簧形式。你提到了你用力按压的卷曲金属弹簧。你还会遇到可以拉开的卷曲金属弹簧。
So on the edges of a trampoline, if you dismantle a clothespin, like one might do on a weekend, you'll find a torsion spring. So that's where you twist it, and it holds energy and twisting. So it's a very versatile piece of design. So let's talk about the way the springs are used in buildings. And specifically, you have an example about a concert hall. So how does that all work? And why do you put springs and buildings in this way? So these springs are on the opposite end of the spectrum to the small springs that we've been talking about, like in clothes pegs or even inside a mechanical watch. These are springs that, you know, I could wrap around my leg to give you some idea of the size of them. And I was really
比如在蹦床的边缘，或者如果你在周末拆开一个衣夹，你会发现一个扭簧。那就是你扭转它，它就会在扭转中储存能量。所以它是一种功能非常多样的设计。那么我们来谈谈弹簧在建筑中的应用。具体来说，你有一个关于音乐厅的例子。这一切是如何运作的？你为什么要以这种方式把弹簧放进建筑里呢？这些弹簧与我们一直在讨论的小弹簧（比如衣夹里的或机械手表内部的弹簧）完全处于光谱的另一端。这些是那种我可以用它缠绕我腿一圈的弹簧，让你对它们的尺寸有个概念。我当时真的
fascinated by this concert hall in Denmark, which is called the Musicians Hoos, or House of them. And I was really fascinated by this concert hall in Denmark, which is called The Musicians' Hoos, or House of Music. And it's become famous worldwide for having incredible acoustics. So what is it about a concert hall that is special or unique, or that might attract people to pay money and to sit in that space. And when I spoke to the designers, their answer to that was silence. Achieving silence is actually extraordinarily challenging. Yeah, so I would think inside of a building that the thing that was sort of like contributing most to the idea of silence was some kind of, you know, acoustic, tiling and baffling and stuff. Where is a spring fit into this?
对丹麦的这座音乐厅着迷，它被称为 Musikkens Hus（音乐之声）。我当时对丹麦的这座音乐厅深感着迷，它被称为 Musikkens Hus（音乐之声）。它因拥有令人难以置信的声学效果而闻名世界。那么，音乐厅有什么特别或独特之处，能够吸引人们花钱去那个空间坐坐呢？当我与设计师交谈时，他们的回答是：寂静。实现寂静实际上具有非凡的挑战性。
So the kind of thing you're describing is very important. And it forms the kind of the inside skin of the space that you're sitting in. The problem comes up when vibrations are coming into the space from the outside. So the stuff you've described, the panels and things stop echoing, as all podcasters know, it creates that nice, flat sound that you don't have bouncing sound everywhere. But if you've got a truck kind of rumbling down the street outside your home, then your panels aren't going to do very
所以我想，在一栋建筑物内部，对实现寂静贡献最大的东西应该某种声学贴砖、吸音板之类的东西。弹簧是怎么扯上关系的呢？你所描述的那种东西非常重要。它构成了你所坐空间的内表面。当外部的振动传入这个空间时，问题就来了。正如所有播客都知道的那样，你描述的那些面板之类的东西可以阻止回声，它创造了那种不错、平坦的声音，不会到处都是弹听回音。但是，如果你家门外的街上有一辆卡车隆隆驶过，那么你的吸音板可就起不了多大作用了。
much. So what you need at that point are springs, because what the springs do is go, oh, here's some vibrations coming in, I'm going to have a little jump and bounce around, and then I'm going to dissipate that energy into heat, and I'm going to stop that energy from going into the recording studio or the concert hall. Okay, so then describe like sort of like physically, what is the house of music in Denmark do with its springs? The house of music has got its big main concert hall, and then it's got lots of other teaching rooms and concert halls around the main concert hall. So the first problem is that you've got
所以在那个时候，你需要的就是弹簧，因为弹簧的作用是：哦，有振动传进来了，我要小小地跳跃和弹跳一下，然后把这些能量耗散成热量，阻止这些能量进入录音室或音乐厅。好的，那么请从物理层面上描述一下，丹麦的音乐之声是如何在其建筑中使用弹簧的？音乐之声拥有其大型的主音乐厅，然后在主音乐厅周围还有许多其他的教学室和音乐厅。所以遇到的第一个问题是，你可能会遇到
music from I don't know like a queen cover band That can infiltrate your Bach concert, which I'm guessing is not a good thing And so the idea is in simple terms that you're suspending Each one of these spaces particularly the main concert hall From springs in all directions, from the ceiling, from the sides of the walls and on the floor as well. So there's basically a room within a room that's attached with springs all around it.
来自我不知道什么皇后乐队翻唱乐队的音乐，它会渗透进你的巴赫音乐会，我猜这可不是什么好事。因此，简单的说，其理念是将每一个空间——尤其是主音乐厅——从各个方向用弹簧悬挂起来，从天花板、墙壁两侧以及地板上都是如此。所以基本上就是一个房间套着另一个房间，四周都用弹簧连接着。
So that when the world vibrates, it's sort of like that energy is dissipated and so the inner room doesn't vibrate. And it's sort of floating in this sort of room. That's exactly right. At the very technical jargon term for it is box in box. So you're basically creating the inside box. You've got springs all around it,
这样当世界振动时，这种能量就会被消散，因此内部的房间就不会振动。它就像是漂浮在这个房间里。完全正确。用非常专业的行话来说，这叫“盒中盒”（box in box）。所以你基本上是创造了一个内部的盒子。四周都是弹簧，
and then you have the outside box, which is the ultimate structure. And acoustic engineers then spend a long time interrogating all the different sounds, you know, coming into a building, the different sounds inside a building and figuring out how do we arrange the springs in the right way at the right frequencies so that we can create that silence. So this next one is going to be just a quick detour or an interlude of sorts on our journey through the Seven Inventions, but I wanted to bring it up because the string was definitely around when people decided to list out all of the simple machines. Why did you elevate the string to this status?
然后你有了外部的盒子，也就是最终的结构。声学工程师随后要花很长时间去审视传入建筑物的所有不同声音、建筑物内部的不同声音，并弄清楚我们如何以正确的频率、正确的方式排列弹簧，从而创造出那种寂静。接下来的这个环节只是我们探索七大发明旅程中的一个小插曲或过渡，但我之所以想提它，是因为当人们决定列出所有简单机械时，绳子绝对已经存在了。你为什么要将绳子提升到这样的地位？
One of the things that really stuns me about String is that it was invented by the Neanderthals and we found a 6mm long piece of String which had twisted fibers to make this piece of engineering and we use almost exactly the same principle to hold up some of the biggest bridges on our planet today. And if you look at a cross section of a cable from a suspension bridge, it really is just like, it's a cross section of string. It has all these little threads, or not little, big threads, put together into one big rope type of thing that's all made out of metal. It just looks, it is string. It is, completely, and that's what I really love about it. And I think the other thing I also love about it is just how beautiful it is.
关于绳子，真正让我震惊的一件事是，它是尼安德特人发明的，我们发现了一段 6 毫米长的绳子碎片，它是通过扭曲纤维制成这一工程制品的，而今天我们使用的几乎完全相同的原理，来支撑我们星球上一些最大的桥梁。如果你看一下悬索桥缆索的横截面，它真的就像——它就是绳子的横截面。它把所有这些细小的线——或者说不小，粗大的线——组合成一根粗大的绳索状金属物。它看起来就是，它就是绳子。它完全就是，这正是我非常喜欢它的地方。我想我同样喜爱它的另一件事是它的美。
String is beautiful. It creates beautiful things, not only physically beautiful things, but also music and where would we be without music? We've been a bouncy concert hall that didn't sound like anything. When we come back, Roma wraps up her list of small inventions that changed the world. And so our next entry in your seven inventions for making the modern world
绳子是美丽的。它创造出美丽的事物，不仅是物理上美丽的事物，还有音乐，如果没有音乐我们会怎样？我们只会有一个听起来空洞无物的弹簧音乐厅。当我们回来时，罗马将总结她改变世界的微小发明清单。所以我们七大发明清单中的下一项，
is one that the engineers during the Renaissance probably never would have considered at all and that's the magnet. Tell me why you chose magnets. Yeah, I mean, I chose them because they're really attractive. As you say, I know, I know, but I'm also, so magnets, as you say, were strictly not an invention, perhaps they were discovered in the form of what we now call load stone. So, there is a form of iron called magnetite and magnetite is found naturally in the world. And so, the ancient Chinese found some of it and were known for creating some of the very early compasses using it for navigation, but we really didn't understand what magnetism
是文艺复兴时期的工程师们可能根本不会考虑的一项，那就是磁铁。请告诉我你为什么选择磁铁。是的，我的意思是我选择它们是因为它们真的很有吸引力。正如你所说，我知道，我知道，但我也——所以磁铁，正如你所说，严格来说并非一项发明，也许它们是以我们现在所称的天然磁石的形式被发现的。所以，有一种叫做磁铁矿的铁的形式，它在世界上是自然存在的。因此，古代中国人发现了一些磁铁矿，并因使用它制造最早的指南针进行导航而闻名，但我们当时并不真正理解什么是磁铁
was and how it worked. And then, fast forward a few thousand years, when we figured out electricity coming into the kind of 18th, 19th centuries, we suddenly realize that electricity and magnetism are in fact very intertwined. So, when it comes to describing the importance of magnets, what objects or what sort of engineering feats did you use to explain that? Yeah, so I mean, I think magnets are really, really key. Magnetism is very key to long-range communications. And the engineer that I talk about is called Jagdish Chandra Abhors. And he's an Indian scientist, and he used to work kind of in colonial India.
以及它是如何运作的。然后，快进几千年，当我们进入 18、19 世纪弄懂了电学时，我们突然意识到电和磁实际上是密不可分的。所以，当谈到描述磁铁的重要性时，你用了哪些物体或哪些工程壮举来解释这一点？是的，我的意思是我认为磁铁真的非常非常关键。磁性对于远程通信至关重要。我谈到的这位工程师名叫贾格迪什·钱德拉·博斯（Jagadish Chandra Bose）。他是一位印度科学家，曾在殖民时期的印度工作。
So in a way, it was fortunate that he was able to do the research that he did. And what he figured out is, with this interaction between electricity and magnetism, you could use electromagnetic waves, so light is an electromagnetic wave, but he was looking at radio waves, slightly different, that you could transmit energy and transmit signals. I mean, of all the inventions in your book, I mean, this is the one where, you know, there's not a physical connection to make the thing work.
所以从某种意义上说，他能够进行自己所做的研究实属幸运。他发现的是，通过电和磁之间的这种相互作用，你可以使用电磁波——光是一种电磁波，但他当时研究的是略有不同的无线电波——你可以传输能量和传输信号。我的意思是，在你书中的所有发明中，我觉得这是唯一一个没有物理连接就能让事情运转的发明。
I don't know, I feel like I don't get high, but this is what I feel like if you get high, this is what you begin to think about, you know, just like how mind-blowing it is to think that a force is exerted across a room And what that means and how revolutionary that is Yeah, it is and to demonstrate this idea Dirk Dishchandrabos set up a public lecture in the late 1800s and he invited the lieutenant governor
我不知道，我觉得如果你嗑了药，这就是你开始思考的那种事情，你知道的，仅仅去思考一种力如何在房间里施加作用，这意味着什么，以及这是多么具有革命性，是多么令人脑洞大开。是的，确实如此。为了演示这个想法，蒂尔克·迪什钱德拉·博斯（Dirk Dishchandra Bose，译者注：原文口误，即前面提到的 Jagadish Chandra Bose）在 19 世纪末举办了一场公开演讲，他邀请了副总督
You know like a British man who had lots of power, God am standing in his room, and then he switched on a transmitter, which generated some electromagnetic waves, and then the waves went through three solid walls and a human body, the waves then arrived at a receiver that he'd set up, and when intercepted, a bell rang, a pistol discharged, and a miniature mine exploded. This was all intentional.
你知道的，就像一个很有权力的英国人，神啊，我正站在他的房间里，然后他打开了一个发射器，产生了一些电磁波，这些波穿过了三堵厚厚的墙和一个人的身体，然后波到达了他设置的一个接收器，当被拦截时，铃铛响了，手枪开火了，一个微型地雷爆炸了。这一切都是刻意安排的。
No one was hurt. But he basically demonstrated that we can use these waves to send signals far away. And when you talk about this kind of idea of how mind-blowing it really is, I think about my grandfather who was sending telegrams a few decades ago. It wasn't that long ago compared to my daughter who swipes a screen on an iPhone or a smartphone, and can place an instant video call to my family in India thanks to magnetism. You mentioned in your book that Bose is a little forgotten in history, and I imagine a lot of this has to do with where he was working and his identity,
没有人受伤。但他基本上证明了我们可以利用这些波向远处发送信号。当你谈到这种真正令人脑洞大开的想法时，我想起了我的祖父，他在几十年前还在发电报。与我女儿在智能手机屏幕上轻轻一划，就能借助磁性与我在印度的家人进行即时视频通话相比，这并没有过去太久。你在书中提到博斯在历史上被人们有些遗忘了，我想这很大程度上与他工作的地方以及他的身份有关，
but there's also something about his character that he didn't totally want to own this invention really. No, so I don't even know whether he would have been allowed to apply for a patent. I guess it would depend on the powers that be deciding what he could and couldn't do. But as a principle, as a scientist, as an engineer, he didn't believe that knowledge should be restricted. He believed that new knowledge was for. And he wanted to leave a legacy. He wanted to kind of almost create offerings from his life. And he didn't believe that there should be a monetary value attached to that. So even though he invented this incredible device,
但他的性格中也有某种东西，那就是他其实并不完全想把这项发明据为己有。对的，所以我甚至不知道他当时是否被允许申请专利。我猜这取决于当权者来决定他能做什么和不能做什么。但作为一名原则性极强的人、一名科学家、一名工程师，他认为知识不应该被垄断。他认为新的知识是属于……他想要留下遗产。他几乎是想把一生的奉献作为礼物留给世人。他不认为这上面应该附加金钱价值。所以尽管他发明了这个不可思议的装置，
specifically, which was called a kohera, which did a very difficult job of receiving an interpreting electromagnetic signals of the sort that he was passing through rooms and people. You know, the radio, Markonnie's invention wouldn't have existed without that, but he never patented it, he never restricted it. And I think which is part of the reason that his name has kind of been lost in history.
具体来说，这个装置被称为“金屑相干器”（coherer），它做了一项非常困难的工作，即接收和解释他穿过房间和人体的那种电磁信号。你知道的，马可尼的发明——无线电如果没有这个就不会存在，但他从未申请专利，从未对其进行限制。我想这也是他的名字在历史上被遗忘的部分原因。
part of the reason that his name has kind of been lost in history. The next invention on your list is the lens. So tell me about the importance of the lens and how people can understand the lens better. So I think of it in two extreme ways just in my own life. So one is that I wear glasses and if I didn't wear glasses I would have quite a bad headache and not be able to see very well. So even on a very everyday basis, the lens is incredibly important to me. And then there's also the other extreme where
这也是他的名字在历史上被遗忘的部分原因。你清单上的下一个发明是透镜。请告诉我透镜的重要性以及人们如何能更好地理解透镜。我在自己的生活中以两种极端的方式看待它。一方面我戴眼镜，如果我不戴眼镜，我会头痛得很厉害，也看不清楚东西。所以即使在非常日常的基础上，透镜对我也极其重要。另一方面，如果不是因为透镜，
I wouldn't have been able to have a biological child had it not been for the lens. Oh, well, explain that more. So this entails starting from a kind of gross slash embarrassing story. OK. Okay. So I'm going to take you back to a draper who was called Antony Van Liovenhook. Okay.
我甚至无法拥有一个属于自己的亲生孩子。哦，能多解释一下吗？这就需要从一个有点恶心加尴尬的故事说起了。好吧。好吧。我将带你们回到一位名叫安东尼·范·列文虎克（Antony Van Leeuwenhoek）的布商那里。
And this is mid 1600s, he was a bit of a loner, a bit obsessive, and he created these very simple small magnifying glasses to look at the threat count on the stuff that he was selling. But then he also decided to put other stuff in front of this lens. So he put blood, he saw blood cells, he put pond water and saw bacteria and algae and all this kind of stuff. And he used to write these really long, descriptive, lyrical letters to the Leonard gentleman of the Royal Society in London about his discoveries. One of the letters, let's say, was written in slightly more sheepish tones, where he assured the learned men of said Royal Society that the sample that he had looked at was not, and I repeat,
那是 17 世纪中叶，他有点离群索居，有点偏执，他制作了这些非常简单的小放大镜，用来查看他所出售的织物上的纱线密度。但随后他也决定把其他东西放在这个透镜前面。所以他放了血，看到了血细胞；他放了池塘水，看到了细菌、藻类和所有这些乱七八糟的东西。他过去常常写一些非常长、富有描述性、抒情的信件，寄给伦敦皇家学会的博学之士们，讲述他的发现。其中一封信，可以说，是用稍微有点羞怯的语气写的，他在信中向皇家学会的博学之士保证，他所观察到的样本不是——我重复一遍，
that the sample that he had looked at was not, and I repeat, was not obtained by defiling himself, but were the remains after conjugal coitus. And so he was the first person recorded to see spam under the microscope. But it wasn't. Oh my goodness. But yeah, he was a great pain to say that he didn't like extract the sperm from his own body himself, that would be sinful. No. And in fact, his exact words that which has been translated from Dutch, if your Lordship
他所观察到的样本不是——我再重复一遍，绝对不是通过亵渎自己身体获取的，而是夫妻同房之后的残留物。因此，他是历史上第一个在显微镜下看到精子的人。但这并不是……哦天哪。但是的，他费尽心思声明他不是自己从身体里提取精子的，那将是罪过。没有。事实上，从荷兰语翻译过来的他的原话是：如果阁下
should consider that these observations may disgust or scandalize the learned. I earnestly beg your Lordship to regard them as private and to publish or destroy them as your Lordship sees fit. Wow. Another character here. Yeah, yeah, but a character. And so again, this is one of those funny situations where it took nearly 200 years before we worked
认为这些观察结果可能会令学者们感到厌恶或丑闻，我恳请阁下将其视为私密，并根据阁下的意愿将其发表或销毁。哇。又是一个奇人。是的，是的，确实是个奇人。所以同样地，这也是那种有趣的情况之一：我们花了将近 200 年的时间才弄明白，
out that the sperm and the egg were both involved in the act of fertilization. And then you get to the story of John Rock and Miriam Menkin, who were the first to fertilize an egg and a sperm in the lab, you know, paving the way for IVF babies, which is what my daughter is. It's so nice. You owe it to a guy who definitely didn't jack off. Definitely not. All right, so we've arrived at the seventh and final invention, which is the pump. Tell me about the pump and its importance to the world of engineering.
精子和卵子都参与了受精过程。然后你就听到了约翰·洛克（John Rock）和米里亚姆·门金（Miriam Menkin）的故事，他们是第一批在实验室里让卵子和精子受精的人，为试管婴儿铺平了道路，我女儿就是试管婴儿。太美好了。你要感谢一个绝对没有打过飞机的人。绝对没有。好了，我们来到了第七项也是最后一项发明，那就是泵。请告诉我泵及其对工程世界的重要性。
So for me, pumps are about life, and I say that because they were invented to support our lives, they were invented to get clean water from a source and bring it to where we lived. They were invented to take disease-ridden sewage away from us. They were invented to irrigate crops. But one of the pumps that I actually talk about, and I'm really proud of talking about this, because I don't know many engineering books that would talk about this kind of pump, is a pump that I got very up close and personal with soon after I had my baby, and that is the breast pump.
对我来说，泵关乎生命，我这么说是因为它们是为了支持我们的生活而被发明的，它们被发明是为了从水源获取清洁水并将其带到我们居住的地方。它们是为了将充满疾病的污水带离我们。它们是为了灌溉庄稼。但我实际要谈论的其中一个泵——而且我为此感到非常自豪，因为我不知道有多少工程学书籍会谈论这种泵——是我在生完孩子后不久曾与之有过非常亲密接触的一个泵，那就是吸奶器。
So, talk to me about the breast pump. I mean, it's not a surprise really that I felt like a dairy cow when using these pumps because the original breast pumps were a derivation of the pumps that were in fact invented for milking cows, which was invented by a couple of men in Australia. And then you come into the sort of 19th century and even the early 20th century and there were all of these really strange contraptions that I don't want anywhere near me that kind of had these big bulbs with tubes coming off them that you had to suck on. Oh, they just look pretty awful. And I don't even know how they would have worked.
所以，跟我聊聊吸奶器吧。我的意思是，当使用这些吸奶器时，我觉得自己像头奶牛，这其实并不让人意外，因为最初的吸奶器源自事实上为挤牛奶发明的机器，那是澳大利亚的几位男性发明的。然后到了19世纪甚至20世纪初，出现了所有这些我绝对不想靠近的极其奇怪的装置，它们有着带管子的大气囊，你必须去吮吸。哦，它们看起来太糟糕了。我甚至不知道它们是怎么运作的。
And it's actually kind of shocked me that it was only really in the 1990s that electrical breast pumps that you could have at home came to market. I had no idea. Was that late? It was really late. And just if I jump back a little bit into the 1950s, that was the first time an engineer said, huh, let me just think about what's a safe amount of pressure on breast tissue. And let me maybe even measure how many times a minute a baby actually sucks so that the breast pump design can somewhat emulate a baby and be marginally safe for women to use. You know that took a while. Yeah well maybe that's why it
而且实际上让我有点震惊的是，直到20世纪90年代，家用电动吸奶器才真正进入市场。我完全不知道。那是那么晚吗？确实很晚。如果我稍微回到20世纪50年代，那是工程师第一次说，嗯，让我考虑一下乳房组织的安全压力是多少。甚至让我测量一下婴儿一分钟实际吮吸多少次，这样吸奶器的设计就可以在某种程度上模仿婴儿，对女性使用来说算得上基本安全。你知道这花了一段时间。是的，也许这就是为什么它
took to the 90s because it took that first. You know like so you wouldn't be sucked into the machine. Yes. But all of it seems extremely late. And it goes to, you know, it points to something that is sort of an undercurrent in your book. And I think sort of probably an undercurrent in your life and the work that I know that you do is just like engineering because women had been excluded from engineering for a long time. These types of innovations, there's these huge blind spots.
花到了90年代才实现，因为需要先完成那个。你知道，就像这样你就不会被吸进机器里。是的。但所有这一切都显得极其迟。这指向了你书中的某种潜流。我想这也可能是你生活中以及我所了解的你所做工作中的一种潜流，那就是工程学，因为女性长期被排斥在工程学之外。这类创新存在着巨大的盲区。
Yeah, I mean, from what I could tell, and I mean, listeners can please get in touch with me if this is not the case, but I couldn't find breast pumps designed by women until just a few years ago. So, you know, you've got men who are very unlikely to ever use them in their lives, designing things for a purpose that they don't understand, really, or they don't physically experience. And so finally, when women started really
是的，我的意思是，据我所知，听众如果有不同情况请随时与我联系，但在几年前之前，我找不到由女性设计的吸奶器。所以，你知道，男士们在生活中几乎不可能使用它们，却在为一个他们并不真正理解、也没有实际体会的目的设计东西。所以最终，当女性真正开始
looking at, you know, what do we actually want from the pump? We don't just want the milk. That's not the only purpose of the pump. So then we started thinking about what are actually the correct design criteria for a breast pump. And that's when we started coming up with things like it should be silent, they could be discreet, they use a smartphone, use an app that's attached to it. And finally, we came up with a design that actually fits inside your bra and that you can walk around with rather than being in a dingy room at the back of your office somewhere strapped to a milking machine. So, I mean, it definitely makes the case for why engineers need to come from all different walks of life. Well, it's such a good book. It made me very happy to read.
关注，你知道，我们对吸奶器究竟有什么需求？我们不只是想要母乳。那不是吸奶器的唯一目的。于是我们开始思考，吸奶器的正确设计标准到底是什么。就在那时，我们开始想出一些点子，比如它应该无声、隐蔽，可以使用智能手机，使用与之配套的应用程序。最后，我们设计出了实际上可以放进胸罩里、你可以带着它四处走动的吸奶器，而不是被绑在挤奶机上，待在办公室某处角落昏暗的房间里。所以，这绝对证明了为什么工程师需要来自各行各业。嗯，这是一本非常棒的书。读完让我感到非常高兴。
And thank you. It'll just give you a greater appreciation for rivets. You'll just walk around and see rivets, you'll go, I like that rivet. That's pretty good rivet right there. Are you saying, Roman, that my book was riveting? No, I'm not saying that. I am saying that.
谢谢你。它会让你对铆钉有更深的欣赏。你到处走看到铆钉时会想，我喜欢那个铆钉。那真是一个相当不错的铆钉。罗曼，你是说我的书很引人入胜吗？不，我不是那个意思。我是那个意思。
Your book is very riveting. Thank you so much, Roma. I appreciate it. Thank you for having me. Roma's book is called Nuts and Bolts, seven small inventions that change the world in a big way. It's available in the UK now, and for pre-order in North America. 99% invisible with produced this week by Jason De Leon, original music by Swan Riaw,
你的书非常引人入胜。非常感谢你，罗马。我很感激。谢谢你邀请我。罗马的书叫做《螺丝与螺母：改变世界七个小发明》。它现在已在英国上市，并在北美开启预售。本周的《99%无形》由杰森·德莱昂制作，原创音乐由斯旺·里奥制作，
sound mix by Hazik Bin Amad Farid. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colesette is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzales, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Losh Madon, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. An extra special thanks and farewell to Sophia Klatsker, who has been my dear friend for decades and came here to help me take this show to the next level and took care of all of us during these huge transitions in the life of the show. There is no amount of gratitude I could express that would adequately thank her for all that she did for us. She is moving
混音由哈齐克·宾·艾哈迈德·法里德完成。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔塞特是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、洛什·马登、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森博格以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢并告别索菲亚·克拉茨克，她几十年来一直是我亲爱的朋友，她来到这里帮助我将这个节目提升到新的水平，并在节目生命的这些重大转型期照顾了我们所有人。我对她为我们所做的一切表达再多的感激都不为过。她将要
back to her true calling in the public sector as the cultural affairs manager for the city of Santa Monica. Her commitment to art and culture being the bedrock of a rich civic life is unparalleled and she's going to just rule at that job. We are so excited for her but we're going to miss her dearly. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too.
回归她在公共部门的真正使命，担任圣莫尼卡市的文化事务经理。她对将艺术和文化作为丰富公民生活基石的承诺是无与伦比的，她定会在那项工作中大显身手。我们为她感到非常兴奋，但我们会深深地想念她。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区、向北六个街区的潘多拉大楼。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars），也可以@节目（99PI org）。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。
You can find links to other stature shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。